sciences quand je retiens venu dans
cette science nous allons aujourd'hui
vous comptez de belles histoires
ceux qui suivent notre page facebook
sauf que nous nous intéressons de près
aux dragons et aux autres mythes et
légendes que les fossiles ont peut-être
pu un jour inspiré c'est certain il n'y
a pas eu besoin d'attendre que la
paléontologie soit inventée pour que
l'humanité commencent à s'intéresser et
à s'interroger sur l'origine et les
propriétés de ces étranges objets menu
des temps immémoriaux que sont les faux
si nos très lointains ancêtres les
gaulois n'ont encore plus lointain que
cela les hommes de cro magnon déjà se
servait de certains fossiles percée des
coquillages ou de beaux morceaux de
l'iss de mer en forme des toiles
certainement pour se confectionner des
parures les grecs eux vénérait certains
fossiles comme en témoigne de découverte
d'ossements anachronique dans des lieux
de fouilles archéologiques
entre 1870 et 1880 les fouilles de la
légendaire cité 2 3 ont révélé des
richesses insoupçonnées dont une
vertèbre énorme daté de 8 millions
d'années mais découverte dans un dépôt
datant lui du xiiie siècle avant notre
ère
le grand historien grec hérodote
rapporte lui même que dans le
péloponnèse d eau géants étaient
exposées dans un temple depuis le 5e
siècle avant jésus-christ de même en
1988 des archéologues allemands
fouillent en un temple dédié à la déesse
héra sur l'île de samos découvrir un
fémur de rhinocéros fossiles
probablement à rhinocéros laineux tout
près de l'hôtel de cérémonie un peu plus
tôt dans les années 70 à quelques
kilomètres de là dans l'acropole denis
coria était découvert un autre fémur de
rhinocéros laineux c'est qu'ils résident
et paléontologique étaient déposés là
suppose-t-on comme des reliques tes
moyens des temps anciens où les titans
et autres géants ravagé le monde
les gisements grecque et notamment ceux
de pikermi et de samos sont aujourd'hui
parfaitement connu des paléontologues
comme étant parmi les plus beaux
gisements de fossiles de la fin du
cénozoïque l'un de ces gisements étaient
connus des anciens grecs sous le nom de
la panne et ma le champ de bataille où
il pensait que dionysos et son armée
d'éléphants avait livré bataille aux
amazones et
versant allait faire rougir les plaines
la couleur rouge de la terre vient en
fait de l'oxydation du fer en climat
tropical climat qui étaient favorables
appelé tant d'animaux exotiques qui ont
laissé tant de fossiles que bien souvent
il n'est besoin que de se baisser pour
ramasser
quand ils ne font pas directement ça y
est en dehors du sol dans le lot il y
avait d'ailleurs bel et bien quelques
proches parents des éléphants et
mastodonte donc ma foi les grecs ne vais
pas tout à fait tort
un tel culte s'il a bien existé ne
serait pas si éloigné de la vénération
que portaient les médiévaux pour
certains fossiles de ma note amant
exposées dans les églises en tant que
sainte relique comme l'a abondamment
documenté cuvier dans ses recherches sur
les ossements fossiles
à moins que ces temples n'est servi de
centre de cabinet du président est
d'ailleurs le premier emprunt romain
jules césar
nantes est pas en forme aujourd'hui
auguste posséder dans sa villa de l'île
de capri sa propre collection de
fossiles
une sorte de cabinet de curiosités à
loin beaucoup de ces fossiles
provenaient des nombreux chantiers de
construction que l'empereur a initié y
figuraient notamment une défense du
mythique sans oublier le crédit doni
ramené du temple grec de tgl était
vénéré d'après sa taille immense et sa
courbure c'était défense serait fort
probablement de sa lien mammouth
les fossiles sont aussi depuis longtemps
utilisées dans la médecine
traditionnelle
lambres qu'on confondait volontiers avec
de l'uriné de l'accvm les bénédicte ou
encore les épines d'oursins fossilisés
était impliqué dans diverses
préparations censé vous prémunir d'à peu
près tous les maux de seconde en
commençant par les troubles
gynécologiques live games la dépression
ou bien encore écrasé mélangé avec du
vent elle vous apportera à n'en point
douter la sécurité du foyer
l'utilisation en médecine traditionnelle
si elle n'a pas passé le cap du siècle
des lumières en occident reste toujours
très pratique et en extrême orient en
chine par exemple où les fossiles sont
appelés dans de dragons et sont
consommés dans le thé c'est ainsi qu'un
beau jour de lui
33 dans une pharmacie des contreforts de
l'himalaya un paléontologue s'est rendu
compte que l'une de ses dents de dragon
appartenait en fait à une espèce
nouvelle de primate géant
le gigantesque itec ce dernier devenu
ensuite très célèbres comme faisant
partie de la courte liste d'espèces
n'ayant pu inspirer le mythe du yéti
l'homme de pékin a connu une histoire
similaire car il provient lui même d'une
colline connu sous le nom de montagne
des eaux de drago rendez vous compte une
espèce d'hominidé aussi rare et il a
failli partir aux tisanes oui bon mais
on va pas jeter la pierre aux chinois à
tout le monde même les amérindiens
faisait ça et c'est quand même d'un
savant chinois qui est venue la toute
première analyse paléontologique digne
de ce nom dans ses essais du bassin des
songes le grand chêne coûts rapporte la
découverte en 1088 de bambou fossiles
dans une province où le bambou ne pousse
normalement pas il en déduit avec brio
que la région devait être autrefois
marécageuse dans un temps très reculés
à l'heure où en europe pour se prépare
fort gear et à partir en terre sainte
pour la première croisade il s'agit ni
plus ni moins d'une prouesse
bref ce charmant intérêt pour les faux
cellule qu'il soit esthétique
scientifique ou ésotériques 10 ne date
pas d'hier
et à défaut d'être toujours rationnels
la pensée humaine exècre les mystères et
la préfère quelques explications aussi
farfelue soit elle alors comment comment
diable ne pas fantasmer sur l'existence
passée d'un terrible dragon dans le
genre d'homme quand on tient devant soi
un os ou titanesque de dinosaures
comment résister à la tentation de ses
explications merveilleusement simple et
séduisante dinosaures égale dragon est
de nos jours personne ne remettra en
question l'idée selon laquelle ce sont
les fossiles de dinosaures qui ont
insufflé la bimbo météo les genres de
des dragons moins que les 5 sens inverse
coco qu'on commence à la verse et ben il
est tout aussi vraisemblable que les
gens d'aujourd'hui sachant l'existence
des dinosaures se soient convaincus
havre pour que les anciennes légendes de
dragon a été basée là-dessus
non parce qu'il faut bien l'admettre des
légendes impliquant des fossiles y en a
peut-être quelques unes mais des
légendes qui font directement le lien
entre dinosaures et dragons ça court pas
les rues
prenons le dragon de klagenfurt une
ville d'autriche au moyen-âge le
folklore local rapporte que la ville
aurait été fondée vers 1250 après qu'un
terrible dragon est été terrassé la sous
les assauts de breuil chevalier une
statue monumentale et grandeur nature a
été érigé sur la place du village pour
commémorer ce haut fait et voici qu'en
1353 un carrier découvre le crâne d'une
dette énorme qu'on attribue
immédiatement aux dragons pendant cinq
siècles cette pièce magnifique sera
fièrement exposée dans le hall de
l'hôtel de ville comme témoignage du
triangle de klagenfurt oit sur la
terrible bête il faudrait attendre mini
140 pour qu'enfin un paléontologue de
passage identifie formellement la peine
il s'agit d'un crâne d'un dinosaure et
non domino séance ligne datant de la
dernière ère glaciaire
toujours en autriche à mx nits une
grotte aspirer des froids car elle était
remplie doucement on la disait habité
par un dragon
mais une fois étudier le reste se sont
avérées appartenir au nom non toujours
pas voudrais-tu bien arrêter ce à dire
assez pénible madame non pas un
dinosaure mais un ours des cavernes et à
toute sa cohorte de mammifères datant
une fois de plus de la dernière
glaciation le paléontologue autrichien
voter ni rebelle en 1914 rapporte ainsi
plusieurs autres aux histoires
similaires en autriche et en suisse
bon d'accord chercher du côté des
dragons ça n'avait pas l'air d'être la
bonne solution
bon tu aurais pas genre des légendes
basé sur des fossiles de dinosaures plus
tolérée si si si j'en ai les empreintes
de dinosaures de saint-laurent très près
de barre-des-cévennes serait celle de
gargantua montante à paris non compressé
violente des secrète possible situé dans
ce qui est devenu aujourd'hui de
dinosaur provincial park au canada était
vénérée par les indiens pique nique en
évitant le grand père de tous les
buffles
pas mal mais au portugal près de la
chapelle notre dame du cap et speech
elle des traces de dinosaures sauropodes
ont été prises pour celle de la nulle
gérance de la nombre géante sainte
vierge quoi commencer une blague ça
c'est tout ce que tu as à me donner la
hache et si oui une marrante des
peintures pariétales heures réalisées
par des indiens navajos ressemble trait
pour trait les empreintes de dinosaures
carnivores
on s'est même qu'il y avait un lieu
couvert d'empreintes attribue
aujourd'hui aux dinosaures équipes
désignées comme étant l'endroit des
pistes d'oiseaux de 0,1
c'est pas mal ça va continuer mieux
encore à l'autre bout du monde les
aborigènes d'australie on peut attribuer
des simples à buzz en train de
dinosaures à leurs hommes et me
légendaire pour moi c'est un dragon
m'est arrivé c'est vachement cool en
fait alors il ya ces deux peuples qui
ont été les premiers à reconnaître que
ses empreintes appartenaient à des
dinosaures c'est bien ça c'est bien cela
bon bah du coup si c'est des dinosaures
ben c'est pas des dragons un fait banal
go adrienne meilleure mine historienne
spécialisée dans la question à fouiller
le sujet de fond en comble il n'ya rien
des bisons ou des buffles au géant pour
les amérindiens des êtres humains géant
en europe et au moyen-orient
elle admet même la possibilité d'un lien
assez équivoque entre le proto ceratops
et la légende du griffon mais pas de
dragon à part les chinois qui appelle
absolument tous leurs fossiles des eaux
ou des dragons ils sont que ce n'est que
très récemment qu'on a commencé à
vouloir des dinosaures partout où il n'y
avait jadis que des dragons objection
votre honneur
j'ai fait des recherches et je connais
eun légende la plus connue des légendes
de dragon en france celle de la tarasque
tellement connue qu'elle a même fait
l'objet de même sur le net
la thématique est un monstre qui aurai
en t la région de tarascon dans le sud
de la france à la fin de l'antiquité
romaine
quand on est en plein dans l'époque de
la christianisation sainte-marthe
prêchée par la nouvelle voie et fit
promettre village
de tous se convertir si elle parvenait à
vaincre la bête la fin fut vite réglé on
est un signe de croix la bête fut apaisé
et sainte-marthe la ramena ainsi amadour
et en se servant de sa ceinture comme
d'une laisse ou de son foulard selon les
versions
la vindicte populaire n'épargna pas la
bête puis tous se convertir
c'est une bien belle histoire en est
n'est ce pas ehealth un hasard si cette
histoire ainsi que des dizaines d'autres
comptent les ravages de dragon de
serpents géants et de basilic justement
dans la vallée du rhône l'une des
régions de france où se trouvent les
plus importants gisements de dinosaures
je ne crois pas non
tiens c'est vrai on a même donné le nom
de thérèse cause aux usa l'un d'entre
eux et puisque je te le dis est ce un
hasard si le basilic des légendes avec
son corps de poulet et sa queue de
serpent ressemble autant à un dinosaure
aa oui oui bon mais attend elle ne m'a
pas trop vite non plus regarde mieux
telle carte
ton raisonnement marche bien pour la
vallée du rhône les regarde la normandie
où on a découvert plein de fossiles de
dinosaures
pas une seule légende et regarde au sud
de paris que c'est le contraire moult
les langues mais pointe fossiles
oui bon bah la superposition de cartes
c'est pas non plus une science exacte
annoncé sur est assez petit jeu là voici
la carte des mammifères fossiles
découverts en france tu vois comme la
vallée du rhône ressort bien mais mieux
qu'avec la dino zoff moi c'est vrai que
ça marche vachement mieux comme ça bon
bah je dois m'incliner alors c'est vrai
qu'en même temps c'est pas facile de
trouver un os de dinosaures même quand
on en cherche et oui ils sont trop rares
trop profondément enterrés vie trop
fragile pour plus quelqu'un qui ne sait
pas exactement ce qui fait qu'ils se
prendre toutes les précautions
nécessaires à son extraction
al'inverse les mammifères géants de la
fin du quaternaire comme les mammouths
où les rhinocéros laineux par exemple
n'ont que quelques milliers d'années
leurs offres sont ainsi très souvent
restées intactes et on les trouve en
grandes quantités dans des strates de
surface sur le bord des rivières ou dans
des grottes ou parfois même on n'a même
pas besoin de creuser alors doit-on en
déduire que ce sont les mammifères de
l'âge de glace qui ont inspiré les
légions des dragons en france
à klagenfurt si l'on en croit
l'historien béranger ferraud qui a
activement travaillé à rassembler dans
un seul ouvrage la plupart des légendes
de dragon française c'est tout sauf
aussi simple que ça les mythes peuvent
avoir de multiples origines
une curiosité géologique intrigante un
lac une grotte ou même encore
l'existence d'un joyau précieux dans une
famille de nobles certaines légendes
sont amenés appris qu'une dépouille de
crocodile ramené par quelques pèlerins
marchands ou croisé était pendu comme
que il dit dans une église et ce malgré
le fait que l'on connaisse pertinemment
l'origine véritable de la relique
c'est notamment le cas pour le dragon de
paris de marseille ou encore de l'hôtel
dieu de lyon et qui sait si le crocodile
offert par l'empereur rochus la ville de
nîmes et qui lui sert toujours d'emblème
n'a pas un jour donné des idées à
quelques compteurs camargue
mais le plus important reste de remettre
ces histoires dans leur perspective
historique
ce qu'il convient de rappeler c'est que
les dragons les serpents et les petits
bleus manière générale ont toujours
servi de symbole du mal quand ils ne
sont pas eux-mêmes l'incarnation de
satan dans la mythologie chrétienne
dès les premières pages de la bible
l'agente reptilienne est utilisé comme
une allégorie du diable le serpent
infâme tentateur incitant route péché
originel pour l'imagerie populaire
chrétienne le dragon plus ou moins
serpentiforme est complètement
interchangeables avec le diable comme en
témoigne à l'archange saint-michel
célèbre pourfendeur de la bête mais qui
se trouve être tantôt représenté sous
les traits d'un missile ou de satan
lui-même
quand on veut comprendre les origines
des beats des dragons il ne faut donc
pas oublier que pour les premiers
chrétiens d'occident le dragon est l
incarnation du mal absolu
j'ai nommé le monde à gagny
c'est un peu donc quand on parle du
fascisme en ces termes la bête immonde
et la légende du dragon vaincu bas c'est
tout simplement une métaphore pour
parler de la christianisation une sorte
de propagande si vous préférez des
histoires racontées par les évangélistes
pour mettre en images la puissance de
leur croyance en pays non converties
d'ailleurs ce n'est pas pour rien que de
nombreux redessine ne sont que des
copier coller les uns des autres
en tout point similaire à l'histoire de
sainte marthe par exemple un saint un
dragon malfaisants le saint combat de
dragon avec des prières et des signes de
croix puis le tient en laisse avec saint
satur avant de le pour forme
généralement le précipitant dans un trou
le tout accommodé à la sauce des us et
coutumes des légendes locales
c'est toujours un saint qui terrasse au
dragon au sinon c'est moins nobles et
dans ce cas c'est la noblesse locale qui
tire la notoriété et le profit du
prestige du récit clergé et la noblesse
vous sentez comme le voyage pointe le
bout de son nez humain
finalement les mythes des dragons
peuvent tout aussi bien n'avoir rien à
voir avec les fossiles ou même avec un
quelconque événement qui est plus
exister un jour les fossiles peuvent
être à l'origine de vieilles croyances
locales
mais le tout a été passé à la moulinette
durant si longtemps qu'il est le plus
souvent impossible de le prouver
et si vous pensez qu'on ne peut pas
inventer des histoires pareilles de
toutes pièces demandez vous combien de
temps cela prendra avant que le bouche à
oreille ne transforme en dragon les déjà
mythique d'alligator des égouts de paris
ou bien encore le serpent qui s'allonge
à côté de sa maîtresse pour voir s'il
est juste assez long pour la manger
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il
n'existe qu'un seul mythe reliant les
dinosaures aux dragons et ce mythe c'est
que les premiers auraient inspiré les
seconds et oui en fait les dinosaures
ont inspiré les dragons c'est ça le 8
merci à tous pour en savoir plus nous
vous conseillons la lecture de
l'histoire des mammifères de francis
duranthon ainsi que celle de first
console hunters par adrienne mayor et
pour les plus téméraires c'est de la
superstition des survivances de béranger
ferraud